à 80 km du centre de kiev une habitante
filmé ces images
sous ses fenêtres des chars russes à
l'offensive
à l'est du pays kharkiv deuxième fils
ukrainienne là c'est un centre
commercial qui est bombardée
au nord à l'est et au sud de l'ukraine
voici les zones occupées à 7h par les
troupes de vladimir poutine ce matin le
porte parole du ministère russe de la
défense se félicite
l'aviation russe a conquis une
supériorité aérienne sur l'ensemble du
territoire de l'ukraine au total depuis
le début de l'opération nos forces
armées ont frappé plus de mille éléments
de l'infrastructure militaire de
l'ukraine sur plusieurs fronts les
attaques russes font des dégâts dépôts
pétroliers
zones d'habitation en pleine ville
mais l'ukraine continue de résister au
sud de la capitale ces réservistes
ukrainiens se tiennent prêts à riposter
la situation n'est pas la même partout
dans les endroits c'est pire des
endroits c'est mieux
par exemple ici le dépôt pétrolier de la
ville d'à côté a été bombardé cette nuit
et tout près d'ici ce sont des attaques
ponctuelles
à 40 km de là dans ce centre culturel
des civils font des provisions certains
se disent prêts à s'engager pour leur
pays
moi je suis de pierrefonds mais je suis
coincé
je veux être utile et je veux faire
quelque chose pour aider mon pays à se
défendre contre l'agression russe
au cinquième jour de l'offensive russe
sur l'ukraine le sort du pays est
suspendu à l'issue des négociations en
cours